[Music]
congratulations on warrior you
collaborated with a lot of rock artists
on this Iggy Pop yeah he's my favorite
okay how did you get a key pop to be on
your album uh it took a couple years and
I'm really good at stalking people so I
got I like knew somebody that knew him
and I just kept emailing them they
change their email address and then I
like I've literally stalked him you
stalk a key pop yeah okay so what will
you say that mean like you were in a
darkened van outside his house I mean
kind of I do tend to do that but I just
like weasel my way to like get to him
and then finally he's like fine and I
guess and then it's my favorite song
right rainy shower at the time probably
yeah how did you know it's just true
you've claimed that you have broken into
the homes of famous people well not well
yeah that's a pretty simple question you
broke into their homes
what do you mean you really broke into
their homes drink anything I went under
a fence I did though but did they know
that you were there well when I was like
hey Prince so you broke into Prince's
home I did a long time ago okay what's
the statute of limitations legally on a
crime like that so you went into his
home was he surprised to see you now you
looked excited and surprised this should
be a reality show
there should be reality show Kesha
breaks into celebrity homes
don't be fun - why I would watch that
every wind you watch you have a very
close relationship with your fans to the
point that you asked each of your fans
to send you a tooth yeah okay let's talk
about that a little more what what was
the plan what was the plan you get the
teeth well I just I don't know okay so I
like wearing body parts as jewelry so I
thought I wanted to wear my fans cuz I
love my fans with anything in the world
right so I thought they could send me
their teeth and then I made a headdress
out of him and I went and I'd like a
thousand so now I'm making a bra said
something drinking a bra out of human
teeth okay say it like that it sounds
really weird but it looks
instead of bra of human teeth I don't
know what that's gonna feel you know the
bottom part out Oh smart idea right
that's right and there's actually a
picture of my book of my headdress that
I made out of my fans teeth when you
walk in my house that's the first thing
you see
but it's so fantastic I know that gives
me a great idea for our fans
I don't know we would ask our fans for
you've done teeth I don't know and there
aren't a lot of body parts that were you
know I mean I think no oh okay no we're
not gonna do that
you said I have to ask you sir Tony out
of time that you've slept with a ghost I
have to ask you have you slept with a
ghost I did go to the bone zone with a
ghost yes those did whoa was it a ghost
of a famous person was it I mean I I
don't know his name but he was in my
house you don't know his name why is the
ghost and so he just started like
caressing me like this this story is
getting better and so then things
proceeded from there right it was a sexy
time it wasn't like sex I love it I
absolutely love it
don't even know the guys name